this is debate club here's a guy did I
fellas tuning in from Down Under coming
at you with that Moffatt 19 now I've got
a quick one for you
Quentin Tarantino films or Martin
Scorsese any hoozy orangutangs but fuzz
cheers boys to day so cheers me what do
you think Quentin Tarantino Scorsese
films mmm Quinton Tino be Django once
upon a time in Hollywood Pulp Fiction
Kill Bill one and two dusk till dawn
dusk till dawn reservoirs for rooms yeah
so it's kind of easy for me okay I would
go with uh couldn't aunty know all the
goddamn day once we find that once upon
time Hollywood's top three for me well
Martin Scorsese's Goodfellas Casino the
Irish man wolf on Wall Street what else
I think it will fall in Wall Street here
did I make that up did he not do well he
did well from Wall Street who did silver
lining playbook either one of them
nope oh he did the depart is the
departed it goes hard the partying that
good bra oh you bow out your call ya'll
brother you just don't understand it
gangs in New York goes hard yes all
right Jerry he did the 50-year argument
got her silver linings playbook was
David O'Russell yeah but so really with
uh with Martin Scorsese it's [ __ ]
casino Goodfellas right that's his big
boys against pulp fiction and what be
this biggest one Pulp Fiction and what
do you think Joe chapell I would go with
Tarantino okay Browns fans II know for
me too Tarantino
I'll go with your boys [ __ ] on all of
Martin's movies but I did yep alright
then I'll
I wish one had done Groundhog Day but
Tarantino that
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]